let's keep the drew's news train of
chugging all right
we've got to drive that's so cute let's
go i love it liz
christine chelsea one of our beautiful
writers on our drew's news crew
thank you we've got a drew gooder on the
news who's known as the funnel cake
queen from
decatur alabama for years kenya congress
has been quietly
funneling uh-huh cute her profits right
back
to her customers and her community
please welcome kenya
hi hello hello
how is everyone this morning we're great
and we're talking to you and that's why
kenya how do you funnel your cake
business
to help others well we take a percentage
of our profit a day and we put it to the
side
and at the end of the day we'll see who
needs help or maybe it's a big bill
and we'll wait until the end of the week
to help someone
and then sometimes i don't pay myself so
that way we can help people out in the
community
i'm really excited because for christmas
we are gifting a family
or a person a single mom or father
twenty five hundred dollars to make
their christmas memorable
i love that that is so great and i love
you doing such good work and also
representing the funnel cake which is an
underrepresented cake
thank you for doing that and you
actually were able
to go um a woman allowed you to
open a pop-up shop if you will in her
store
and now you have your own brick and
mortar
yes she uh we were closing
home of grace and that's how we started
with funnel cakes
and she came by to buy a table and so
she was telling me that i could come
in her storefront and i was excited but
i wanted a food trailer
and so when we ended up opening um
there we outgrew it so fast and we ended
up getting our own location
i love that you're do gooding
um or drew gooding of course but it's
all about you kenya
thank you really is a success right now
but i know that you
take everything that you get and you
give it away
so we would like to cover this 2500
contribution for you um
[Applause]
and this is your decision you get to
delegate it wherever you want
we just thought we if it's okay we'd
like to contribute to it and
take it off your plate um and then also
you need to do something for yourself
when you take care of everybody else
so we're getting this gift is
non-transferable
you cannot give it away ross tell her
what she's
won okay you ready for this we're gonna
send you on a seven night all-inclusive
trip for two with spa
treatments to the royalton punta cana
resort and casino
it's the perfect escape for the ultimate
vacation with
swim out suites and eight world-class
dining options and
steps from the beach and you put the fun
in funnel and the heart
into christmas and we want to do
something that you cannot give away
and you must take for yourself because
you are so altruistic
and deserving you we're just following
in your footsteps trying to take care of
you the way you take care of everybody
else
this is amazing thank you i think you're
amazing
thank you thank you so much kenya for
everything you do and your
business will be on our website so go to
the drewberrymore show.com
and check out kenya's incredible funnel
cakes and her whole world and her giving
and thank you kenya for being on the
show
thank you keep it up kenya all right
you